former Patriot Patriot Hall of Famer now
rodney harrison football night in
America analyst hey rod congrats that
was awesome I love the speech that you
gave thanks man how are you man good
there good to hear from you man it's
been too long brother well it was nice
that the Patriots honored you and then I
started to think will you ever get one
of those gold jackets how important is
that to just being considered for the
Hall of Fame you talking about the NFL
Hall of Fame yes well you know Dan it's
a lot of politics that goes be behind
that situation and you know I look at a
guy like Terrell Owens who I felt like
should have been a first-ballot Hall of
family he's one of the top two or three
receivers that I've ever faced and you
know it's something going on sometimes I
think it's personal but it's a damn
shame the fact that the Patriots have
such a dynasty we get Ty Law but there's
so many other guys that are so deserving
of consideration Richard Seymour
obviously was one of those guys Willie
McGinest you know even tell you I gotta
like Tedy Bruschi deserves consideration
I feel like myself you know it's cuz I
think it's just unfair I'm like I said
earlier you know how do you get punished
for being on the greatest dynasty of all
time but why do you think that the media
doesn't recognize some of these
defensive players because Gronk's going
in Brady's going in Bella checks going
in I don't know who else you know
Edelman may be on the fringe of it but I
don't think he's a hall-of-famer why
haven't we recognized some of these
other players certainly the defensive
players of the Patriots I think the
danger is there with with the Patriots
everyone buys into the team concept so
no one's run around parading you know
putting themselves above the team
everyone buys it to the team system and
although it's a team concept you know
people have the tendency to just say hey
it's Bronk and if it's on Brady and his
Belichick which those those guys are
definitely at the forefront of the
dynasty but there are so many other
players that came through there were
unbelievable players that never asked
for recognition took less money and did
whatever they had to do over the course
of their career to be part of
championship teams it's highly unfair
guys should get recognized more and it's
a shame it's an embarrassment to the
league and I just don't know how you can
look at the Patriot
team the last team that went
back-to-back championships and oh three
and oh four the old seven team all the
success that the Patriots had six
championships in eighteen years how
could you not recognize more guys it's
unfair and like I said earlier in the
week I feel like it's a form of
discrimination guys not getting
recognized but thank God tile all got
recognized because he definitely
deserves to go but you and you kind of
stumbled upon something here that maybe
it's just everybody looks at the
Patriots and they're different from
anybody else in the NFL I don't know if
you know there's an adverse reaction
when people talk about hey Ben's a Hall
of Famer or Antonio Brown when he was
there you know we look at different
franchises differently than we do the
Patriots it feels like yeah and like I
said before I mean it's unfortunate and
you know what if the bottom line is I
don't need that to validate my career
anything like that the Patriots honor
and being there with the fans voting in
they know I mean I was against Richard
Seymour my brave Oh two really great
players and the fans know they come out
they see us play they know the bride
they know all the adversity that we face
as individuals as a team and you know
they vote for who they you know feel
like belongs in the Hall of Fame
unfortunately a lot of other times
people follow certain narratives oh the
Patriots just the team guy those guys
that are voting in the Hall of Fame they
don't go back and watch tape they don't
truly go back and watch tape on a lot of
these great players to kind of
refreshing themselves like you know so
it's just unfortunate but at the end of
day man I got my championship rings and
and I was evolving into the Patriots
Hall of Fame I'm ecstatic about that
can you believe Brady's turning 42 you
know what I can't I got a chance to talk
with him and he's just he's loving it
man like he feels good and think about a
day and I was a teacher at the training
camp practice and they're walking around
everybody's walking around it's not
training camp it's like it's summer camp
you know these guys are my practice in
there they're barely hitting guys are
jogging around looking good and shorts
and t-shirts I mean like if I wanna play
to this day and age I probably would
have played 20 years
well why is it different at a training
camp now well I think they're just
trying to keep everyone safe and healthy
you heard Julio Jones come out and say
you know he did he doesn't even need
preseason games and it's one of those
things where you know they're trying to
keep guys from getting hurt but what
happens is when you abstain from cut
physical contact that much during the
regular during the preseason
well when the regular season comes and
you started getting hit that's when guys
starting to break down and I don't know
if there's evidence to say that because
they're doing less hitting guys are
staying fans healthier longer or their
plan longer so I don't know about those
stats but at the end of the day man it
was just weird saying those guys not
really practice to a day like we used to
practice back in the day Rodney Harrison
football night america analysts and
Patriots Hall of Famer you once said
that you took Tom Brady for granted and
the quote was he's like the Michael
Jordan of football so now man just just
the level of professionalism you know
just you know Willie Willie McGinnis and
myself got a chance to speak to the team
and and really just see him just to see
him as part of one of those 90 guys in
that room how humble he was being around
him it's the same Tom Brady he's hungry
he doesn't look at his accomplishments
he sits back and he just says wow like
you know I got to continue to work and
we've seen that Tom Brady has gotten
better each year he looks great he feels
like he can play a few more years so I'm
really excited about it the top 100 list
that the NFL Network put out had Aaron
Donald as the number one player in the
sport this is voted on by the players I
don't know what the exact criteria is is
he the best player at his position I you
know second on the list is Drew Brees
know like what do you make of Easley is
Aaron Donald the best player in football
absolutely absolutely the best player
overplayed it I mean you see a guy that
dominates the way he dominates
consistently beat double teams open it
up avenues for his other teammates and
you have to you have to really change
your entire offensive game plan to block
this guy got it to play inside outside
left right he just repented every time I
watch him walk now I am thoroughly
impressed he's the best
all day on the planet period and then
you're trying to you know Khalil Mack is
in there Patrick mahomes is in Brady is
in the top 10 but I think he's like
eight or something my god it's weird the
list I hate these lists because I I
don't know I guess we're doing what they
want us to do and that's disgust argue
list like this but the aaron donald one
i have no problem with that with him
being the the best player in football
it's just it feels like it's such a
quarterback driven league that the
quarterbacks should all be in the top
ten well i mean obviously i mean Patrick
mahomes should be right there after the
season are we talking about the body of
work of your career or the previous
season so it's a lot of different
criteria that we truly don't understand
as fans but at the bottom line the guys
that have depressed me most this past
season was Aaron Donald number one at
Patrick mahomes number two you also look
at the running back position we've been
talking about this with the holdout with
Melvin Gordon with Ezekiel Elliott and
and you know running backs are the ones
that probably need their contracts
guaranteed more than anybody and they're
their careers don't last as long there
one amongst the lowest of position
players paid in the NFL what happened to
that position Ron I don't think it was
just ever really a position that was
valued I think the NFL a lot of coaches
and general manners kind of blackballed
the position so you wouldn't have to pay
guys and it's unfortunate but if I'm
Ezekiel Elliott you know I don't I don't
think he's gonna win this situation
because he had the time he's have has
this year left which is like three nine
three nine twenty nine million
he has next year which is about nine
million and then they can actually
franchise it at probably about twelve or
thirteen million bucks so the Cowboys
they don't have to do anything right now
at this point and the fact that you know
the Cowboys had stuff with Ezekiel
Elliott through a lot of tough times in
the fact that even its latest incident
he still has the nerve to try to hold
out I would think in good faith he would
try to come back be in training camp
work toward a championship and hopefully
a deal could be done but I'm with Jerry
Jones I'm not breaking the bank repair
running back as vql is great player but
at the end of the day of Mary Cooper is
far more important
in my eye for them to win a championship
because of Mars because hmm that
Prescott needs a wide receiver you're
gonna pay this got kid 30 million
dollars a year and just the hand the
ball off no you need him to be able to
have big plays and we saw the impact
Amari Cooper has so the priority list
have to be dak Prescott for Marty Cooper
and then some of those guys on defense
then Ezekiel Elliott in my belief you
know see I thought differently I thought
you gotta sell the you know the run so
that play-action is the quarterbacks
best friend and if he got Zeke there I'm
gonna buy into the play-action far more
than if I you know he's not there and
then that makes him re Cooper better so
I saw it differently than you did no not
necessarily Dan I think what you're
saying is right but you can't pay
everybody and why would you go with a
guy that potentially has basically three
years left on his contract and go and
pay this guy when you can't trust them
you can't trust the fact that he's
coming off this rookie deal and he's
getting all these incidents imagine if
you give them 50 or 70 million and you
guarantee in 40 or 50 million can you
trust that guy to do the right thing on
the field off the field and everything
that encompasses being a highly to pay
or the highest paid running back in the
league
the Cowboys back is not against the wall
and what he has to do Jerry Jones has
set a precedent that hey you're not
going to bully us into contract that
Prescott is the priority Amari Cooper
has to be number two then you look at
some of the defensive players you know
Jaylon Smith by Byron Jones those guys
need contracts you can't just build and
spend so much money at the running back
position I give you a prime example look
at the Patriots the Patriots probably
have four or five running backs that's
making 12 or 13 million dollars combined
so why would you go out and spend 14 15
million dollars on a running back that
consistently has gotten in trouble I
love the VLE but the bottom line is can
the organization trust him with 50 or 60
million dollars and I don't think they
can't at this point in time and that's
the reason why I feel like they're not
going to make him a priority in these
negotiations yes your mom I I wouldn't
give him a lot of guaranteed money
because I'd say look you you put
yourself in this position we're going to
extend you we're gonna pay you an
average of whatever
but guaranteed money is not your gonna
have to earn your guaranteed money we're
not going to give that to you upfront
we're gonna make you earn it maybe
towards the back end that would be the
way if I could approach it and say look
we'll rip up a deal or extend your
current deal but you know these are the
parameters for us what do you think of
that approach I don't think the victor
Ellie will pay these guys they don't
want that year-to-year approach they
want guaranteed money especially now
that you see a guy like Michael Thomas
who's been a who's been great off the
field who's been great on the field
who's done all the right things he's
never said anything although he's done
is produced and when you get a kid like
that it's rare that you find a great
player that's a good person off off the
field you always have to take care of
those players and 20 million dollars a
year I figured that would be that's a
great price for him I think it's a fair
deal and you know but when you talk
about a guy that's been up and down in
trouble coming off his rookie deal
expecting to get paid big money the big
question is can we trust this kid as an
organization to do the right thing that
if you can't trust them you can't have
what was better Bella checks shirt than
he had on at your ceremony or Bella
checks speech his speech was fantastic
and it was really humbling to me that
Coach and I've heard him talk before
that the level of respect that he had so
I mean he was just so complimentary and
it was just a pleasure playing with him
playing for him but God just gave me a
tremendous amount of freedom let me play
didn't have any didn't tell me to hold
back just let me have my normal
personality on the seal so playing for
Coach Belichick was an absolute honor
and I don't think you're gonna meet too
many X players that didn't enjoy their
experience with coach Belichick it was
great I was proud for you and hopefully
there's a bigger picture there with the
Pro Football Hall of Famer at least get
consideration there rod great to talk to
you bringing it as always thank you
Rodney Harrison for more Dan Patrick
show tune in the audience channel 239 on
DirecTV stream for free on BR live or
download the Dan Patrick show app
[Music]